because you never signed to a major
right you stayed independent this whole
time yeah i'm sure everyone was trying
to sign you i mean yeah i've had
interview interviews i had a meeting
with a bunch of people but it's like
i don't think it's worth it yeah yeah
what was um for you why why
did you and puya kind of make that
decision to stay indy
so when you first started making music
right
it started popping off right and
obviously you monetize it on tunecore
distro whatever right
yeah all that [ __ ]
we started making money here
we went on tour we literally called
cities
all around the country and booked venues
ourselves like we booked the venue no
booking agent no booking agent at least
when we first started booked the venue
whatever they wanted boom sell it out
make the money so when we got off tour
we're like yeah we're making money like
real money our streams are kicking in we
just made x amount on tour and we made x
amount selling merchandise on tour so
when we would go to meetings and they
would want x percentage we'd be like
why are we going to give you a
percentage to not guarantee it because
the label can't guarantee you should i
can't guarantee you anything they can
promise you but it's not that's not the
only thing they can guarantee you is the
amount of money they give you up front
and that is the back door for them to
[ __ ] you in the ass yeah so it's like so
i'm gonna take that hopefully you can do
something for me but i still gotta
recoup that and you're still gonna take
like 50 or 60 yes trash which is insane
so i'm like we're good like i know how
much money i can do merchandise i know
how much i get per show and how much i
get streaming so i don't really need you
unless you come up with something crazy
that makes sense for me
yeah like i agree with like distribution
deals and stuff that's cool jvs are cool
like if it's in your favor and stuff